the cradle of the Protestant Reformation
is a town on the river Elbe halfway
between Leipzig and Berlin
the painter Lucas Krannert came here in
1505 the theologian Martin Luther in
1500 and 8 and the philosopher Philip
Melancthon in 1518 much later Wittenberg
became the center of the German
chemicals industry
but it remained the small town and since
1922 it has officially been known as
Luther started Wittenberg Luther's town
it's it's very inspiring that lots of
people with religious beliefs come here
for them this place is very special
and we keep learning from them how
special this place is not just the
church but also the town that has shaped
and influenced so much history it's very
exciting to experience it again and
again especially now that we're
restoring the church for the Reformation
anniversary in 2017 this is a very
exciting time math doesn't douche pass
this is the gunship and it said the city
church is the oldest building in
Wittenberg Martin Luther preached here
five hundred years ago now the church is
facing change and so is the whole of
Wittenberg also you must us once
the major anniversary is fast
approaching in 2017 it will be 500 years
since Luther formulated his famous
Reformation theses Protestants
throughout the world will be celebrating
this occasion and hundreds of thousands
are expected to visit Wittenberg
the residents of this small town are
already used to pilgrims and tourists
especially in the summer most of them
from the United States and Asia
we are come from the Korea South Korea
we are Methodist Church we journey to
the Reformation for religious we we are
going to be a real Christian for that's
why we come here and we look around the
looters doing and life and his sermon we
memorize everything it is own globe
which we few theories next go for the
here conference the visitors are
incredibly varied not just in their
countries of origin of a but also in
their interests since I've been here
I've learned a lot about how Luther
himself and the history of the
Reformation plays a role in various
cultures how its woven into a very wide
variety of national traditions
Martin Luther spent 27 years in
Wittenberg first as an Augustinian monk
and then after leaving the Catholic
Church with his wife Katharina
their former home is now a museum a
highlight for most pilgrims is Luther's
study this is where the great reformer
received his closest friends and this is
where he held his famous informal
speeches the Tishman in the early 16th
century the town on the Elbe had only
2,000 residents but foreign students
boosted its population to almost double
that number rittenberg was a provincial
backwater but it had an internationally
renowned university with famous teachers
back was a little town that achieved
international prominence five hundred
years ago Yvonne University appointed a
young professor in 1508 who changed the
world by the word alone with knowledge
not with power by the power of the word
and not by the command of the powerful
una de lung that tradition endured for
hundreds of years and shaped the town if
you enter the town's main church and
stand in front of the chronic altar you
feel the breath of history as something
very much alive monsieur le bending
isn't
Lucas Cranach the elder was probably the
most important german painter of the
renaissance
he was an apothecary by trade and mayor
of bitten burg in this famous altarpiece
he introduces the protestant reformers
into the biblical scenes at the Last
Supper the man with a light-colored
goblet is Martin Luther masquerading as
a young clerk a disguise Luther used in
Barbara castle to hide from the
Inquisition John the Baptist is Luther's
companion Philip Melancthon
the man with the white beard cranek
himself the image we have of Luther is
largely based on cronix portraits
although the historical Luther was a man
with many facets theologian politician
and poet
repite ah the my older residents of
bitten back remember the communist era
in which Martin Luther wasn't exactly
ignored but was revered as the man who
created German as a written language the
Communists also honored him as a
revolutionary but they ignored him as a
theologian he should however be viewed
in the total context as a theologian and
a politician and as a man of letters
every one can discover something of
interest in Luther but--will minge-y era
can buy lotto atlas physician today if
Wittenberg has a population of nearly
50,000 but only a fraction of that
number live in the old town most reside
in the surrounding conurbation Luther
and Melanson are commemorated on the
town square and their former homes are
unesco world heritage sites along with
the historic churches 80 million euros
has been invested in renovating the
historic center since German
reunification two and a half decades ago
and another 80 million will follow in
the next three years it's a world
heritage site that has influenced every
aspect of society that's why it's being
so intensively restored for 2017 if you
invite guests you spruce up your home
and we're doing that on a big scale
we're restoring both the important
churches and we're supporting the
presentation of Luther's legacy by
creating exhibition rooms linked to a
new definition of content that's a new
point of orientation that will extend
beyond the anniversary year itself
the state government of saxony-anhalt
Germany's federal government and the
European Union are all helping shoulder
the costs
it's a bonanza for this small german
town but then its international
significance is unique
we had some Mallory's visiting from New
Zealand and we spoke English when I
showed them around they kept saying that
they could hardly believe it was real
they were Protestants and for them
Wittenberg was the cradle of the
Protestant faith that they professed it
was like somewhere in heaven they could
hardly believe it really existed on
earth in him it does contig honestly I
cry for after I design
this is also written Berg the piste of
its nitrogen plant Germany's largest
fertilizer manufacturer
in 1915 an enormous chemicals plant was
built in the bitten burg district of
pista it's the tradition of high-tech
chemicals production continued even
during the Communist era and does so
today
all times I graduated in 1973 and wasn't
sure what to do next then a brand new
fertilizer factory was constructed in
vuitton bag and I ended up working here
like a lot of other graduates we were a
very young team we grew up with the
plant and the plant grew up with us
since mitten unlocking of oxen and the
unlock a Midlands
a few minutes away lies the beast of its
housing estate it sprang up between 1915
and 1920 modern accommodation for the
workers he meeping fought for sunshine
headwaters the slogan was chemistry
produces bred prosperity beauty and in
the Communist era everyone who lived
here was employed at the nitrogen plant
it was almost a family tradition my dad
worked here and so did I so did my aunt
and my cousins we all worked at the
plant and lived on the estate it was a
very nice setup everyone got on well
together we were friends and that had an
influence on the children we played
together it was great fun with lots
happening he puffed
the architect splendid as a green area
each house had its own garden and even a
bathroom which was very rare in a
working-class district 100 years ago
during the Communist era the district
became rundown but it was completely
renovated after German reunification and
is now a fashionable neighborhood and
not just with chemical workers it's been
I'm a chemical engineer myself I've
spent a good deal of my working life in
the sector I was elected mayor after
reunification then I asked myself what
is this town really is it only a
chemical site
a choir is rehearsing in the castle
Church the singers are amateurs some of
them haven't lived in Wittenberg very
long as in Luther's day the town still
attracts lots of foreigners the choir
mistress was born in America it's a big
world in a small town everybody's
welcome here Fidan burg is important
historically but it's also a completely
normal town where families live and
people work for me and and a lot of
things happen here that have nothing to
do with Luther its garnishment also true
in that Amy Taylor only arrived a few
days ago she's working at the Lutheran
primary school for a few weeks the 23
year old American is here as a foreign
exchange student more than a thousand
students from all over the world come
and study in Wittenberg each year many
of them bring their lecturers and
curricula with them
and here doing my student teaching I go
to Concordia University in st. Paul and
I'm in the teacher education program
there and I'm in my senior year and my
major is teaching English as a second
language so I had the opportunity to
come here and teach English my
university wants to build a partnership
with Luther set Wittenberg education is
topping the agenda once again in
Wittenberg in 1994 the low career
foundation took over the premises of the
former leukorrhea University with
projects such as the student exchange
program its reestablishing academic life
in the time the organizers look back
with nostalgia on Wittenberg's past
glory 500 years ago when the university
attracted academics from all over Europe
does Vicksburg luta wonderful what's
shown right Wittenberg has become
synonymous with Luther and the
Reformation mainly because the Great
Communicator Luther spread his ideas
from his chair at the University
sign there was a university professor
not a vice which is often overlooked
sorry you're in his living of a meet at
design Watford and he was also a
prolific writer and a first-class
journalist to show for that's why there
were printers here wendy Biden and those
are the two aspects that made the town
world-famous the University and the
business vac imprint on the title page
of publications so we can back state
the end of Wittenberg's glorious past
also has a precise date the town fell to
the Prussian army in 1817 the Prussian
King Friedrich Wilhelm the third closed
the University and turned its buildings
into barracks for his troops
ban Hut naman is the sexton at
Wittenberg's main church and an
enthusiastic Luther impersonator
he has welcomes state premieres prime
ministers and presidents to the time
he's much in demand in this role I think
Martin Luther is the most popular figure
in German history whether he was the
most important I would let others decide
but he's somebody you could imagine
having a beer with and you can't really
imagine doing that with Goethe or the
kings and emperors who had a decisive
influence on German history
then hot nylon guides lots of visitors
through the town and they all love his
tours he knows all of Luther's colorful
expressions
mara Eckert naman and his assistant on
elites are inspecting the construction
work on the town's new shopping center
for most fitting bag residents this
building site is probably more important
than all the town's museums
salamé
the sickle line
there's also construction going on in
front of the shopping center in fact
almost everywhere the urban
infrastructure is being renewed
roadworks are in progress and even a new
train station is being built all before
2017 the new veteran back Center is
being constructed here incorporating the
armory
that's where there'll be a new
exhibition of the town's historical
collections that's the new Arsenal
shopping center and here there'll be an
ensemble of four buildings one of them
the old Franciscan monastery will be the
town's reception center the main office
for welcoming tourists then we have the
city archives and civic center with a
hall that can seat 600 for conferences
and meetings and on the square itself
the market will probably be held again
so that life returns to the area which
has long been dead
sometimes when we came out in the
morning of the nitrogen plant had
admitted some toxins during the night
there was a coating on the pavement and
you could see your footprints it was
mostly soot that was a problem so it was
a huge relief when it was all
reconstructed less than alice on the
water before reunification we had more
than eight thousand workers here then
that numbers suddenly shrank to just 700
not only our own workers were out of a
job but people who worked for all the
other firms in the area now we've become
an important economic factor once again
not just for vit and bag but for the
whole region we're no longer the largest
employer but I think I can say with
pride we're one of the largest tax
payers
another 30 firms are cooperating with a
feast of its chemicals company in a
joint project called the agro chemical
park the plan is to ensure Wittenberg's
economic future beyond 2017 there was an
attempt during the Communist era to
rename Luther's town the atheists wanted
to call it the chemicals town
Whittenburg but the residents resisted
man can Xion eat sang that's meant amiga
gluto you certainly can't playoff
chemistry against Luthor's it's despite
you have to acknowledge that they belong
together reside entity the chemicals
industry is an opportunity to make a
living very few people in fitting bag
can make a living from LuthorCorp which
is not to say that he's not decisively
significant for the town's self-image
niche one can try an epidural is to come
here and witness the door to walk
through the door I walked through the
door a couple of Sundays ago that Martin
Luther nailed his 95 theses to the door
my host mom said you're walking through
the door right now the highlight of
every visitor Wittenberg is the door of
the castle Church where according to
legend Martin Luther nailed his 95
theses condemning the sale of
indulgences on the 31st of October 1517
the original castle Church was severely
damaged in the 18th century and again in
the 19th the brass door that
commemorates Luther's protest only dates
from 1858 historians disagree about
whether Luther really published his
theses here but it's a powerful symbol
I'm 68 and I've lived in written back
for 34 years precisely half my life you
always have to take another look at the
young Luther then you'll see what
dynamite is there every great idea has a
surface of the unattained
and while everything's being beautifully
renovated here I have to think of the
hymn that says gleaming beautifully on
the outside muslin door it's important
that something inward happens and that
everything doesn't just gleam
beautifully on the outside for 2017 a
thousand zips in for now sunshine around
what message will 2017 have for the
residents of Wittenberg most of them
take a practical view of the changes in
their pretty tan some are irritated by
the fuss about Luther only one in five
belongs to the church
one thing certain life will go on beyond
2017 Martin Luther is buried in
Wittenberg's castle church but he never
really felt at home and the famous
university town the cradle of the
Reformation and the place from which his
family came for him Whittenburg was
probably just a bit too small little
burg is the most important small town in
Europe and I think that's what's
interesting that great and important
people were forced to come into contact
with ordinary people on the streets here
to experience normal real life the
worries of simple people I think it's
good that the Reformation came from a
small town Concetta osteitis calmness
with life garbagemen Elsa
you